how did Evolution create so much
beautiful complex variety on Earth
like from that
you're saying that we're talking about
improving different modules but if we
step back and look at the entirety of
the tree of the different organisms that
created all throughout history the the
stuff that's fun to you with the the
first few billion and the the stuff
that's fun to me when I watch on YouTube
which is like the the line versus
gorilla fights and so on uh but the
whole thing is fun so with all that
beautiful variety from the predator and
the prey uh from the self-replicating
bacteria and all that kind of stuff how
to do it how is a very difficult
question especially when we don't
understand
um the past with Clarity at all I can
tell you that there seems to be very
critical innovations that happened
throughout the history of life that are
each themselves
very sophisticated singularities that
emerged once and then they set the tone
one of which is emergence of translation
it seems like it happened once it had to
happen once seems like that's all it
took
3.8 billionaire maybe older
clearly subjected to a lot of chemical
Evolution even prior to the last
Universal common ancestor and then you
jump and you see
um emergence of
cyanobacteria
that's undeniably change the course of
those planets
in the subsequent aerobic
photosynthesis that life learned
how to utilize what's available in the
environment in the most profound way
and then you move forwards you see the
emergence of eukaryotes to this
endosymbiosis also another singular
events and then you move forward and
then comes the plants so these are I
counted I think six different things
that seems to have happened just once
and the singularity events in the
history of evolution of life on Earth so
what's really fascinating here is that
there seems to be two different courses
the time course Evolution or is
operating at the molecular level right
we're talking about
seconds we're talking about mutations
that happen every second we're talking
about selection that's also happening
under a minute right so that is a very
fast process the fact that I can evolve
bacteria in a lab and I say I almost
complainingly oh my goodness it took me
150 days I mean that's pretty rapid to
for for a change to be seen
but then the big changes and the ones
that I'm talking the really big
innovations that increased that cause to
an increase of oxygen on this planet or
even its own mere presence are due to
these molecular Innovations
seems to only happen a handful of times
over billions of years of time scale let
me ask you this question having to do
with my half a sleep tweet
so saying that we all originate from one
common ancestor
um that's just one of them miraculous
things
about life on Earth of course you could
say there's multiple common ancestors in
the beginning multiple organisms and so
on but the other stuff that you're
talking about is these singular events
these leaps of invention throughout
evolutionary history
now there's a bunch of people who were
commenting
a bit surprising to me who were
basically skeptical of this idea the
idea of well I would say Evolution
honestly the process of evolution but
when you just actually focus in on like
holy crap
um eukaryotes were invented holy crap
photosynthesis was invented like those
are incredible inventions and also if we
can go to Homo sapiens think
intelligence like where did that come
from it's it did these Mysteries I think
where that skeptical comments are coming
from were also just a general skepticism
of science
I think from the pandemic people may be
a failure of Institutions and so on they
um
they've been a growing distrust of
Science and it's not so so much that
it's anti-evolution it's it's more of a
stepping back and saying wait a minute
maybe scientists don't have it all
figured out and I think
um to Steel man that case is almost a
step back and to realize there's so much
mystery to each of these leaps right so
it makes you wonder is there something
that in 100 200 years we'll figure out
that we totally don't understand yet
like some you know there's I talked to a
bunch of people about another mystery
which is consciousness right and there's
people called pan psychists who believe
Consciousness is one of the fundamental
laws of the universe so there could be
um
you know like we have laws of physics
that could be something that's like uh
Consciousness field or something that
permeates all matter and so like there
might be uh it's kind of like Newtonian
physics versus general relativity like
we have a good understanding of how
things happen but we need another layer
of understanding to fill in the gaps of
the mysteries of it all and
that sort of is a sobering reality that
maybe there is something we really
deeply don't understand do you have a
sense of where the biggest mysteries
here are is it the origin of life itself
is it the leaps
that we're talking about so you you see
the beauty you're fascinated about the
translation mechanism
but what what are the Deep Mysteries
there to you
we are nothing but chemical systems
capable of
formulating or answering questions about
our own existence
we humans or all of life you think
humans humans are uh I mean the fact
that we can we even have this
conversation about
our
place in the universe is is
that is to our knowledge is quite
specific to our own chemical species
but
yeah it's kind of wild we're we're uh
introspecting on our evolutionary
history and we're just a couple of
organisms
yes I would like another organism
listening to this and like they're mind
blown there's like three organisms two
of them talking and the third one's like
holy [ __ ]
life or or even contemplating about our
own place in the universe if at the end
of this would come down to appreciating
uh or even before appreciating really
truly comprehending what it is that we
got here
um that to me is a huge gain because
there's no single question in biology I
think that will give that
the that would deliver that magnitude of
that message and understanding but
understanding how life here started at
first place if we truly comprehend that
we this is not a concept that is well
thought in schools we ask students to
memorize these Concepts maybe if they
are lucky they learned RNA world
chicken and egg problem
Etc that's the extent to which that God
may be their biology teacher was
personally interested in the subject
matter if they're lucky and you know the
saying that the the
uh brain brains are
evenly distributed uh across any metric
you can imagine but opportunities are
not
so if people aren't understanding the
importance of this is because that's a
lack of opportunity right there that's
was skipped through
the
proper Education and Training then the
delivery of why
Science Matters or how science actually
works yeah but how do you even begin to
uh
I seriously think about the origin of
life
I mean
every problem
of existence of life
has its time so I don't know if it's
time to understand Consciousness yet we
might be a hundred years away from that
the origin of life I don't know if it's
time for us to understand that yet maybe
we need to solve so many more problems
along the way and so the composition of
problems right so there are all kinds of
problems and it takes a lot of people to
make the world so you will always have
some interesting brain in going after an
interesting problem to their own the
issue here is that we we need to first
of all understand that we what we have
going on on this planet is pretty good
good planets are hard to find
if we are alone in the universe that's
that's huge
we need to take care of what we got here
and we are incredibly vulnerable to the
changes that our own species also helped
create a on at the biosphere at the
ecosystem level we take it for granted
we take what we created for granted
because of the fact that we think we are
some sort of ultimate endpoint the most
sophisticated amazing thing that nature
could generate
I think understanding and not even
understanding but asking these questions
of where did this even come from how did
this even begin and
attempting to understand that using
chemistry and physics and biology and
because we can
That's The Ultimate Gift we can give
back to the entire species on this
planet
yeah I mean it's humbling it's humbling
to realize the the complexity of this
whole mechanism it certainly puts humans
in their proper perspective that we're
not
um just because we have brains and
brains are intelligent doesn't mean
we're the most intelligent thing because
ultimately the the whole mechanism of
nature seems to be orders and magnitude
more intelligent all all of it like
we're we're a bunch we're like a
hierarchy of organisms that have a
history of several billion years and
that all somehow came together to make a
human and there'll be life after us
just as it was life before us and
something that comes after will be
perhaps even more fascinating
yeah I think when you understand the
magnitude of what happened here there is
there is no room for arrogance it should
overwhelm you and humiliate it's pretty
humiliating yeah like you know it's it's
it's quite amazing what what what was
what happened here and there is no other
discipline that will
deliver that but exploring our own
Origins and looking at Life as a more
planetary system phenomena rather than
one single species at a time a
collective look